things like the first day of hearing the
beat I'm just listening to it in my
headphones like mmm any I'm just
following the melody of the beginning
and then the line just comes to me what
was the line yeah I'm gonna take more
silicon Road did you even know how to
ride a horse not much how much I dunno a
year ago Montero Hill now known as lil
nas ex says he was sleeping on his
sister's floor does this feel like old
town road I mean could you have gotten
any better with chickens before he came
to this Atlanta studio I mean you first
heard that beat and you thought what I
thought I hope nobody gets this B before
me yeah cuz cuz what did you hear in it
what did you hear it sound like an
anthem to me I don't hear those like
that often where you just know is like
this time is special
and so then you paid $30 for it yes I
leased it for about 30 bucks when I got
that money together and then I had to
wait another month until I could go into
the studio for like $20 Tuesdays just
one hour yes all you need
you know I'm thinking Montero it takes a
lot to make dreams come true so you're
having goose bumps coming back here coz
when was last time you hear last time I
was here is probably what very early
this year around time I made this song
maybe
wait this is small in here so you did
that song in here yeah
simplicity is king David Morgan who goes
by Cinco was the engineer on the
original recording I can't say I knew it
was a hit but I knew it was a good song
and I expressed that it was different
and I felt that different is good
and I remember telling him that you
never know what different can do for you
gonna do this you get into the studio
and you decide to put a country twist on
it no no I knew from the start of
hitting the beat I was gonna put like a
country twist on it
were you a country music fan not
necessarily what was your thinking about
how it had to sound I wanted to paint a
picture of like depressed kind of cowboy
going to a better life and I wanted this
to be like a sad leaving song in the
beginning but then just kind of like
turned into like a banger you know by
then you sort of thought I'm on to
something here didn't you think that I'm
on my way the day this song came out I
knew I was on to something I knew if I
pushed this as hard as I could just keep
this momentum going I'm going to have
something and had something he did you
know he dropped out of college because
he wanted to concentrate on his music
the Sanko guy the engineer was also very
cool because he said this is a very
simple studios you see so there's no
distractions no ping-pong no video games
or you come in here and you just work
and that's what they did in less than it
look in about an hour if he took the
budget session he's got to make sure he
has it up I love what Senko says when he
says you never know what different can
do for you yeah
$20 Tuesday so you go in the studio and
you get an hour for $20 30 bucks for the
beat yeah any bucks for the studio it's
a $50 yeah that's right and it's already
had over a billion streams audio and
video of people who have seen or
listened to that song and bought that
song